The Joe Rogan experience.
And one of the things that I wanted to talk to you,
cause I haven't talked to you since the pandemic start.
Last time I talked to you was screwball, right? Like how long.
Ago was that? Oh yeah. What? 2019. Yeah, it was 20.
Right before the hit the fan. That was the last time we talked. Yeah.
And we were talking about that documentary and then when all this happened and
so much of the wackiness, the, you know, the controversy's coming outta Florida,
like you embrace the chaos of Florida.
Yeah.
Florida fuckery is our genre and it's our also our top export I think,
is as well. It's really what we provide the rest of the, but for you.
And you, I mean, look about how much your work is about Florida,
the cowboy series, you know,
all the stuff on Arod like all the there's, there's so much of your,
your work.
The petrifying, I'm a Florida native, you know, in a lifelong Miami.
And I think the petrifying thing that I've learned through the years,
and it's not my theory, uh, TD Allman called Miami,
the city of the future and effectively the Florida of today is the
curve tomorrow. And more importantly, the Miami of today,
more specifically the Miami of today is the America of tomorrow.
So if you want to know what, uh,
challenges will face or calamities will befall us as a nation in the years or
even decades to come. And you need to only look at the Canary in the coal mine,
which is, which is south.
Florida. Do you think that's because of it's very vulnerable to climate change,
first of all, right? Like there's,
there's estimates about how long Miami can last. Yeah.
Not good. Yeah.
They don't grip. They think it got about two decades. Right? Isn't that the,
the current.
Thought I'm a renter. Let me put you that way.
<laugh> I've lived there my whole life. I don't own any property in Miami.
It's probably move. I'm not bullish. It does. It.
Seems like it's gonna go underwater.
Right? Yeah. It'll definitely be underwater. It's just a question of when,
just a.
Question. Cause it's all like there, like the, the ground itself is very porous.
Is that correct?
Yeah. I mean, you know, we have, uh, uh, reclaimed wetlands, that's Miami beach.
That's where Champlain towers is reclaimed wetlands. What does that mean?
It was mangroves. Swamps. Yeah. Swamp. And that we reclaimed,
which means we filled it in and there's still porous limestone underneath that
Champlain towers only had water coming at it from the front,
the back above and below. But other than that, it was totally dry.
This is the tower that collapsed. Collapsed. Yeah. I mean just battered.
We're getting battered then they.
Were on that porous limestone. Yeah.
That was oh yeah. Yeah. Built on reclaim wetlands.
And so I'll tell you right now, as we speak, this is the, um,
the king tides. You know what the king tides are? No,
they happen every September, October and November, not the entire time,
but there's like a week here, a weekend there for those three months.
It is what we call sunny day flooding. So it has to do with the tides.
It has to do with the, the, the dish between the sun and the moon and the earth.
And it floods in the sunlight. It,
we can get as much as 12 inches,
12 inches above the highest high tide of the
year.
So it just, it's not.
From rain. It's not now here's the problem. We're still in hurricane season,
which means rain exacerbates it. Inclement weather can,
we're totally when it rains on top of the king ties.
But this is just like a day. Like you just,
if you are in a low lying area or waterfront or ocean front bay, front,
that's just what sunny day. It's perfectly. It could be perfectly beautiful.
And you could have as much as 12 inches above the highest.
High tide. So it's just an unusual level of the ocean.
Yeah. It's just a cork of, of the tides. It happens every year, uh,
off and on for three months. Yeah. That's in,
in the day we call it sunny day flooding. That's a thing that we have there.
I mean, you know, Miami, we make it rain, but we, now we have sunny sunny day.
Flooding is a thing. Uh, and there's.
Nothing they can do. Like new Orleans, like put up some sort of a,
some sort of a wall.
So the,
the army Corps of engineers proposed a kind of futuristic post apocalyptic,
you know, after the flood, well,
pre flood kind of a wall and Miami said, no GAC. No,
thank you. We don't want that. We'll we'll, we'll we'll fend for ourselves.
Did they.
Say no because it was too expensive? Or did they say no because.
No, the army Corps of engineers I think was gonna,
everything was gonna be federally funded.
They just didn't want this unsightly unseemly kind of a wall in our beautiful
town. And, but what they did want is they wanted a signature bridge building,
like this $800 million bridge that we don't need. That's but it's, it's super,
it's super pretty. As we say in Miami, it's.
Super pretty. And somebody probably got a good.
Deal. Oh yeah. Oh, you better believe the contractors. That's the thing.
That's why the Miami of today is the America of tomorrow.
It's really the corruption dysfunction in nonstop construction.
That's really what it is. It's this?
Anything go wild west kind of mentality because you know, I,
I said this before on the show, you know,
LA is where you go when you want to be somebody,
New York is where you go when you are somebody and Miami is where you go,
when you want to be somebody else. Yeah.
It's always been a sunny place for shady people. The Florida man phenomenon.
It's just like, you know, it just, if you have,
it's not new England, it's not, what's your name? Who's your daddy.
Everyone's new Ric in Miami. So no one cares where your money came from.
As long as the booze is flowing and everybody's dancing, the music's going,
nobody gives a.
And it's always been that place. It's always been that party place. You were,
you were telling me before, about how during, uh, with, was it the seventies,
the eighties, these recording artists would go down to.
Miami. Yeah, listen, uh, Miami is just it's America's Casablanca,
you know? And so some of the biggest records of all time, um,
I mean back when that was the business,
like you could sell tens of millions of albums. Uh, everybody went to Miami.
Eric Clapton was one of the first Jimmy buffet, the BGS, the Eagles,
Crosby stills, Nash, and young, um, the Alman brothers Fleetwood Mac,
and they were doing all those records that we all still know today from the
seventies, they recorded a mixed or mastered at least in part, um, uh,
uh, uh,
Glen fry and Don Henley wrote the lyrics to hotel California in a rented mansion
on Miami beach ha uh, where it had that had been the love nest, um,
of Howard Hughes. And I agar, uh, uh, Winston Churchill used it as a,
a winter home. Uh, and, um,
the w Watergate burglar and Howard hunt used it as well. And then, um,
Steven stills used it. He was hanging out there with like shell Silverstein.
They were, it was like a weird scene. And then, uh,
eventually the Eagles came down to do hotel California and wrote the lyrics.
They locked themselves, these two guys in a room and they, they just,
the housekeeper left sandwiches and drinks at the door cause the door was closed
and they came down in bathrobes one day with, with legal pads, yellow,
legal pads, and said, we have it. We have, we have, we have the lyrics. Wow.
And so everybody, every, and it was a, a communal scene too.
It's kinda like your place with the, you know, everybody sort of like stops,
tested, people's stop by to get it.
It was like that because you had all these artists in every route, like,
so there was pickup basketball games outside,
you'd drive up and there'd be the BGS playing the Alman brothers,
playing Eric Clapton in a pickup basketball game. And they,
to this day criteria studios, they have an, a wooden upright piano.
And the rumor has it.
One day there was an artist I won't mention in the name was playing and had a
baggy of cocaine on the top of the piano.
And he was playing and the baggy fell open, fell, boom,
puff a smoke on the keys of the piano appropriately.
And he grabbed the bag and salvage what he could.
And then for the next several months, the people,
the studio who worked at the would stick a straw between the key on the,
on the piano and try to say mostly dust. They were probably snorting, but like,
but just trying to salvage whatever they could for their, so the, the, the,
the joke was that, um, they had, uh,
a line item on the, uh, the bills that,
because that's the thing they were away from the watchful is iners of the
labels, which were all based in New York and LA.
So they would go Miami and no one knew what the was going.
I didn't have publicists or producers from, or executives rather from,
from the recording studio.
So they would send them bills to pay for the studio time.
There'd be a line item for cocaine, but you couldn't say cocaine. Um,
and I think by the way,
cocaine was at that time was probably part of the appeal of bringing the artist
to Miami, to be fair, probably right. But it was under the,
the category of piano tuning <laugh> was, was the cooking.
So you get like some, you know, someone at, you know,
accounts and at a record label would call up and say, Hey,
I have a question about this, this invoice, um, it's, it's,
there's $5,000 here for piano tuning, but there's only one ballot on the album.
So let's with all this piano tuning, you have it there's there was an act,
oh God, I I'm not gonna say it.
But there was a band who came down in the eighties to record a criteria.
And then they came down again in the nineties and the guy who runs the studio,
Trevor, his mom was the manager before him.
So he was a little kid running around this scene.
If you can imagine a little kid in Miami,
in the seventies running around this scene, this is an incredible place.
Aretha Franklin, did the respect record at criteria James Brown,
did I feel good? Recorded that song at criteria. It's a really historic place.
And so he, this band comes in and he says the lead singer. He says, Hey, listen,
I don't know if you remember, you know, you were down here 15 years ago,
whatever, back in the late seventies, early eighties doing this, this record.
And the singer says,
I have no memory of that whatsoever.
Except for one thing, he said, one night,
apparently we were done recording here.
And someone took us into the neighborhood.
It's like in a residential kind of area into the neighborhood,
to this woman's house. And she brought out a brick of cocaine,
an entire kilo of cocaine. He said,
I'd never seen that before she put it down on the coffee table,
we're sitting on the couch, she put it down. And like, this is a big band. Uh,
they put it, she put it down on the coffee table. She cut it open.
And all I remember from my entire experience in Miami is the smell of that
entire kilo of cocaine. Like just what it feels like when an entire, the,
like an entire kilo of cocaine is opened up before you and it hits
and it hits you. Have you ever done Coke? Never me.
Neither. Never, but hearing that I want never <laugh>.
I just wanna know that's a takeaway for that. Wanna know what that's like,
watch the entire episode for free only on Spotify.